I saw the CBS Sunday morning piece and I
thought that was really good
JD was upset he didn't make it into the
piece cuz Sal and Steve nawicki and
Richard got in yeah I went I took the
camera into their room I took the camera
over to a writing area and I actually
took them to JD's area and I explained
to them what JD does but they didn't use
that JD was kind of bummed out about it
I thought for sure you'd make it in well
you can't feel bad about it by much the
tape with them what Ronnie three hours
two and a half two inches yeah let you
out I heard you texted Jason saying you
were a little bummed out yeah whatever
what'd you do uh-huh I talked about
Marvin I think as I watch it was good I
look to you I didn't see I was like yeah
I didn't make the piece do you
understand every other word like me yeah
his mom but then what happened JD puppet
fun for mom and mother okay flowers and
paste I say be honest again I missed it
I talked to my mom for Mother's Day and
she watched the piece that she said it
was good and I looked for you and I
didn't see you I said yeah I didn't make
the piece he's upset about it but he
doesn't really say he's upset about it
was he but you should see he wrote to
Jason and I just know who I'm talking to
well I'm sending stuff like that this
CBS piece put the whole crew and office
in turmoil you know where Shirley was
yeah I know where he was he was hanging
out at where lithium the offices with
Madison so I started here okay because
my office is on 3737 why are you lying
in the lithium offices when we I came
down here because I was told to hang out
here and then when they didn't have a
spot for me here they said you can go
you don't need to be here that's it fine
so I went around to go back to 37
Madison was standing there and she's
completely panicked and she goes oh my
god
Howard's coming by here you have to stay
here you have to help me I wasn't coming
to talk to her I was I didn't know what
was going on she pulled me in her office
and told me to sit there until the
[ __ ] show walked by you should have
said I have work to do and I hid in the
corner if you notice but I wasn't like I
was jumping in front of the camera this
guy though he turns into a total fun
he's an [ __ ] in the hallway anyways
but if he doesn't get in the on the air
two or three times you didn't see me in
the piece did you know you were you were
help the general impression was that you
made sure you got into the lithium
office because you know can I go I
didn't want to be on camera ask him ask
um yeah they told Shirley to go back up
to his office but he's somehow circled
for sure you were gonna zoom by
Madison's office at 100 miles an hour
I'm like there's no way he's stopping
here but why were you there just cause
Madison asks you you just happened to be
security but you don't go that way to 37
the complete it's Howard
the break room I was right here admit it
that you when did it get on the show
there's no spot beyond yeah I know you
won't they told him
body back in the office knows it's true
they told me go back up to his office
she couldn't handle it so he went
complete away is a break room on 37th
why didn't he go to the break room oh
she wants to be on the CBS Sunday
morning that's what every way back it's
not the complete opposite way if you
want to grab a drink the break rooms a
break room when I hung a right to go
down the hall Madison's office is right
there she's grabbed me and pulled me in
her office and told me stay here why not
say I have to go to work I did a G bag
okay who's your boss Madison or him my
point is well-taken that this CBS Sunday
morning these guys are like hungry
wolves for air time and it just threw
everybody off